بالعوده للملف الاوكراني والاجتماعات
المنعقده في ادم برايا ضم الينا ضيفنا من
هناك السيد
وهو وزير الدفاع
الاستوني اهلا بك سيد هذا الاجتماع الذي
تشاركون فيه هو ليس الاول من نوعه لكن هذه
المره ما الذي تبحثونه بالدرجه الاولى
حيث قدم عدد من المساهمين
استثماراتهم وساره الوقت من اجل نبدا
توزيع هذه الموارد هذا اولا ثانيا نبحث في
كيفيه
تكثيف وتعزيز هذا التعاون في منطقه
بحر البلطيق وكذلك في شمال
التهديدات التي تواجهنا الان من روسيا في
اوكرانيا
الى تزايد وليس الى تراجع وبالتالي يجب ان
يكون مستعدين للتصرف والتحرق سريع هذا هو
بالتحديد الهدف من هذا اللقاء ومن ضروره
التسريع يا هذا التعاون ومن نقاشنا حتى
نكون سريعيا حتى اسرع من الناتو وهل
استونيا الدوله المجاوره لروسيا تعتقد بان
الدول الداعمه لاوكرانيا الدول الغربيه
بالدرجه الاولى مستعده وتقوم بما يلزم
لدعم اوكرانيا
قدمت مساهمه كبيره في دعامها اوكرانيا
قريبه تقريبا ثلثه
ميزانياتنا الدفاعيه ثانويه عاليه
وهذا من اعلى المستويات ونسب المئويه في
العالم وسنستمر في مساعدات اوكرانيا
وسوف نسعى الى نشر رسالتي نفسها مع كل يا
حلا فائنا نحن نرى ان الكثير من الدول لا
تتدخل وسعا وطبعا سويتا وحدنا جهودنا
يمكننا ان نحقيقه المزيد يسعدنا ان نرى
بولندا ودول ايضا تكلفه جهوده
تحدث عن صندوق الدولي الذي انشاناهم منذ
اشهر حيث يمكن لعددا من
المانحه او الجهات المساهمه ان تجمع
استثماراتها في صندوق واحدا موحد حتى نقوم
بتقديم المساعدات موحده ونجد خيارات من
خلال البحث من مصادر اخرى استونيا من
الدول التي كانت دائما تدعو الى مساعده
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الثقيله لدعممها في هذه
الحرب ما تعليقك على ما قاله الرئيس
الامريكي جوبيدا بان بلاده لن تجازف
بالدخول في حرب عالميه الثالثه من خلال
توفير مقاتلات امريكيه همم الى اوكرانيا
وانها ستقدم العقودات المعقوله فقط لها
السيد هاني سمعت سؤالي
اعيد السؤال اللي ضيفنا وزير الدفاع
الاستوني هل هو يسمعني الان سالتك عن
الدعم اللي اوكرانيا استونيا من الدول
التي
تدعو الى تقديم السلاح الثقيل وكل الدعم
العسكري اوكرانيا ما تعليقك على كلام
الرئيس
الامريكي بانه
لن يقدمه
مقاتلات الامريكيه لاوكرانيا تفاديا
للدخول في حرب عالميه ثالثه
سيد هان هل تسمعني الان
بالنسبه الى الدعم الذي قدم تضوي الغربيه
الى اوكرانيا
فبصوره اساسيه تمحوره حول
الذخائر وعدد من الاسلحه والان مع وصول
الشتاء بدانا نفكر بتوفير الخيام وعدد من
اجهزه التدفئه وكذلك الملابس وكل ما تحتاج
اليه اوكرانيا وقوتها من اجل ان تقاتل
والدفاع عن ارضها ونقوم به سويها هو تدريب
وتعليم القوات الاوكرانيه حتى تكون اكثر
استعدادا للقتال
روان
لهذا هي المساعده التي توفرها الدول
الغربيه لاوكرانيا حاليا طبعا نحن كلنا
ندرك ان اوكرانيا تقاتل حفاظا على ارضها
وشعبها
لكنك لم تجبني على كلام الرئيس الامريكي
بالتحديد ما تعليقك عليه هو يقول لن نجذب
بالدخول في حرب عالميه ثالثه ولن نقدم
مقاتلات امريكيه لاوكرانيه
كل من يعطي المساعدات له الحق في ان يحدد
ما هو نوع المساعدات التي هو مساعدتهم الى
تقديمها طبعا حين ننظر الى مختلف خيارات
المساعدات على كل دوله ان تختار
وان تقرر هذا هو موقفي اذا كان هذا هو
الموقف الامريكي فهذا هو الموقف الامريكي
سونيا وفاره داخل
بالاضافه الى ملابس وكذلك همم مستشفى
عسكري ميداني كل دوله لها قرارها ولها
خيارها حاليا
ليس لدينا تحالف مثل تحالف شقه حلف شمال
الاطلسي حيث يقرر التحالف المساله تعود
الى كل دوله على حده ان تقرر المساعدات
الى اوكرانيا في الحكومه وزير الخارجيه
الاستوني كان قد قال ان الحرب الاوكرانيه
تضع مستقبل الهيكل مني لاوروبا كله على
المحك- هل هناك خطوه واضحه لتجاوز هذه
المعضله الامنيه
الاكبر لحلف الناتو هذا يعني انا هذا
الحلف عليه ان يتكيف مع الوضع الحالي
ومع التغيير الذي حصل طبعا هل شمال
الاطلسي النيته لديه الاستجابه الملائمه
ونحن نقوم بصياغه خطه اقليميه جديده
وهيكاليه جديده هذا ما نعمل عليه حاليا
هذه الخطط الاقليميه
الحديثه على الارجاح سوف يتم ال همم
صح عينها في ربما الربيع المقبل لدول
الاعضاء في شهر اربعه ابريل وربما في شهر
سبعه يوليو قد نشهد الاستجابه الجديده من
جانب حلف شمال الاطلسي بالنسبه همم
الدفاعيه لمختلف ج نبقى على حال فاذا نعم
نحن نستجيب او نرد على هذا التهديد الذي
تشكله روسيا ونحن نقوم بكل الخطوات
اللازمه حتى نكون مستعدين للحفاظ والدفاع
عن اراضي حل الشمال الاطلسي شكرا جزيلا لك
همم وزير الدفاع الاستوني
حدثنا من ادمرها حيث تعقد الاجتماعات
الخاصه بوزاره الدفاع من هناك شكرا جزيلا
لك